[Music]
it's impossible to explain this
relationship to anyone outside of it we
just cut a baby out of a woman's womb
she asked us to we didn't just like do
it she's the funny one
my sister and I do work that is
groundbreaking but hopeful radical but
safe
[Music]
the way that women
it is world changing how does that
vomit-inducing idealism translate into
dollars I do my job to help people baby
sister who are so deliciously perfect
where do you come from
are you okay
you want me to throw you a baby out of
nothing bring it on let's do the
research let's make anything happen
[Music]
that is not what we want to be doing
though but it might be but it's not but
it could be but it's not
what a Frankenstein
[Music]
I really like her what she means none of
your business everything's my business
not this
[Music]
they're both brilliant they're both
liabilities we are extraordinary
we're a psychopath oh well if I'm the
psycho you're a psycho we are as close
to Perfection as you can get that is
just nuts I love it
you don't need anyone else
you never have you're looking really
crazy for a while there as it turns out
I'm really sane isn't that wonderful
[Music]